tee-shirts rouges symbole ici sur ce
boulevard du général de gaulle de la
lutte pour les droits des travailleurs
sauf que dans cette rôtisserie
c'est avant tout l'uniforme mieux la
qualité de vie des employés semble être
l'une des priorités de ce gérant et pour
cause quand un employé se sent bien dans
son travail il va venir il va pas venir
à reculons marche arrière par exemple il
va venir vraiment parce qu'il sait qu'il
est dans de bonnes conditions de travail
à 39 ans il veut innover prône un
management plus souple où la parole de
l'employé compte de façon à ce que le
travail se fasse dans une atmosphère
détendue bien ces bols en général et a
pas de souci nous sommes une petite
équipe contre la famille donc ça se
passe très bien
manager de façon plus humaine valoriser
le travail de ses employés métaux trouvé
par ce gérant pour éviter une forme de
souffrance au travail
quand on aime les gens et le bon vous
aimez également sur une façon de dire
que si on s'occupe bien des personnes
avec lesquelles on travaille
ils vont vous le rendre un moment donné
voilà donc c'est bien pour ça pour qu'on
souhaite
mais ce conte avant leurs compétences
mettre en avant le fait qu'ils soient
des travailleurs de vrais travailleurs
et qu'on ne peut pas juste l'autre
demande de travailler sans qu'il ne soit
bien encadré
prochaine étape pour ce jeune manager
l'organisation vendredi d'une table
ronde où salariés et dirigeants pourront
tout se dire